so we're living through a pandemic
right now globally in the in the united
states
from an economics perspective how do you
think this pandemic
will change the world it's been
remarkable and you know
it's horrible how many people have
suffered the amount of death
the economic destruction um it's also
striking just the
amount of change in work that i've seen
um in the last 20 weeks i've seen more
change than there were in the previous
20 years there's been nothing like it
since
probably the world war ii mobilization
in terms of reorganizing our economy
you know the most obvious one is the
shift to remote work
and i and many other people stopped you
know going into the office and teaching
my students in person
i did a study on this with a bunch of
colleagues at mit and elsewhere
and what we found was that before the
pandemic in the beginning of 2020
about one in six a little over 15
percent of americans were working
remotely
when the pandemic hit that grew steadily
and hit 50 percent
roughly half of americans working at
home so a complete transformation
and of course it wasn't even it wasn't
like everybody did it if you're an
information worker professional if you
work mainly with data
then you're much more likely to work at
home if you're a manufacturing worker
you know working
with other people or physical things
then it wasn't so easy
to work at home and instead those people
were much more likely to become
uh laid off or unemployed so it's been
something that has had very disparate
effects on different parts of the
uh workforce do you think do you think
it's going to be sticky
in a sense that after vaccine comes out
and the economy reopens
do you think remote work will continue
that's a great question i my hypothesis
is yes a lot of it will
you know of course some of it will go
back but a surprising amount of it will
stay
i personally you know for instance i
moved my uh seminars my academic
seminars to zoom
and i was surprised how well it worked
yeah
i mean obviously we were able to reach a
much broader audience so we have people
tuning in from europe
and you know other countries just all
over the united states for that matter
i also actually found that in many ways
is more egalitarian you know we use the
chat feature and other tools
and grad students and others who might
have been a little shy about speaking up
we now kind of have
more of ability for lots of voices and
they're answering each other's questions
so you kind of get
parallel like if someone had some a
question about you know
some of the data or a reference or
whatever then someone else in the chat
would answer it
and the whole thing just became like a
higher bandwidth higher quality
uh thing so i thought that was kind of
interesting i think a lot of people are
discovering
that these tools that you know thanks to
to technologists have been developed
over the past
decade they're a lot more powerful than
we thought i mean of all the terrible
things we've seen with covet and the
real failure of many of our institutions
that i thought would work better
one area that's been a bright spot is
our technologies
you know bandwidth has held up pretty
well um
and all of our email and other tools
have just you know scaled up
kind of gracefully so that's been that's
been a plus
economists call this question of whether
it'll go back hysteresis
the question is like when you boil an
egg after it gets cold again it stays
hard and i think that we're going to
have a fair amount of hysteresis in the
economy we're going to move to this new
we have moved to a new remote work
system
and it's not going to snap all the way
back to where it was before
one of the things that worries me
is that the people with lots of
followers on twitter
and people with voices people that can
voices that can be magnified by you know
reporters and all that kind of stuff
are the people that fall into this
category that we were referring to just
now
where they can still function and be
successful with remote work
and then there is a kind of quite quiet
suffering of what feels like millions of
people
whose jobs are disturbed
profoundly by this pandemic but they
don't have many followers on twitter
what do we and and uh
again i apologize but i've been reading
the rise and fall of the third
reich and there's a connection to the
depression on the american side
there's a deep complicated connection to
how
suffering can turn into forces that
potentially
change the world in in um
destructive ways so like it's something
i worry about i was like what
is the suffering going to materialize
itself in five ten years yeah that's
something you worry about
think about it's like the center of what
i worry about
and and let me break it down to two
parts you know there's a moral and
ethical aspect to it we need to relieve
this suffering i mean i'm i
share the values of i think most
americans we like to see shared
prosperity or most people on the planet
and we would like to see people not
falling behind and they have fallen
behind
not just due to covert but in the
previous couple of decades
median income has barely moved you know
depending on how you measure it
and the incomes of the top one percent
have have skyrocketed
and our part of that is due to the ways
technology has been used part of it's
been due to frankly our political system
has continually
shifted more wealth into those people
who have the powerful interest
so there's just a i think a moral
imperative to do a better job and
ultimately
we're all going to be wealthier if more
people can contribute more people have
the wherewithal
but the second thing is that there's a
real political risk i'm not a political
scientist but
you don't have to be one i think to see
how
a lot of people are really upset with
they're getting a raw deal
and uh they are going to
you know they want to smash the system
in different ways in 2016
and 2018 and and now i think there are a
lot of people who are looking at the
political system and they feel like it's
not working for them and they just want
to
do something radical um unfortunately
demagogues
have harnessed that in a way that is
pretty destructive to the country um
and an analogy i see is what happened
with trade
you know almost every economist thinks
that free trade is a good thing
that when two people voluntarily
exchange almost by definition
they're both better off if it's
voluntary
and so generally trade is a good thing
but they also recognize that trade can
uh lead to uneven effects that
there can be winners and losers in in
some of the people um who
didn't have the skills to compete with
somebody else or didn't have um
other assets um and and so trade can
shift prices in ways that are averse
to some people um so there's a
formula that economists have which is
that you have free trade
but then you compensate the people who
were hurt and
free trade makes the pie bigger and
since the pie is bigger it's possible
for
everyone to be better off you can make
the winners better off but you can also
compensate those who
don't win and so they end up being
better off as well
what happened was that we didn't fulfill
that promise we did have some more
increased free trade in the 80s and 90s
but we didn't compensate the people who
were hurt
and so they felt like the you know the
people in power reneged on the bargain
and i think they did
and so then there's a backlash against
trade and now
both political parties but especially
trump and company
have really pushed back against free
trade
ultimately that's bad for the country
ultimately that's bad for living
standards but
in a way i can understand that people
felt they were betrayed
technology has a lot of similar
characteristics
technology can make us all better off
it makes the pie bigger it creates
wealth and health but it can also be
uneven not everyone automatically
benefits
it's possible for some people even the
majority of people to get left behind
while a small group benefits
what most economists would say well
let's make the pie bigger but let's make
sure we adjust the system so we
compensate the people who are hurt
and since the pie is bigger we can make
the rich richer we can make the middle
class richer we can make the poor richer
mathematically everyone could be better
off but again we're not doing that
and again people are saying this isn't
working for us
and again instead of fixing the
distribution
a lot of people are beginning to say hey
technology sucks
we've got to stop it let's throw rocks
at the google bus let's blow it up
let's blow it up and you know there were
the luddites
almost exactly 200 years ago who smashed
the looms and the spinning machines
because they felt like those machines
weren't helping them
we have a real imperative not just to do
the morally right thing
but to do the thing that is going to
save the country which is make sure
that we create not just prosperity but
shared prosperity
you